So here in Shots
of Awe, we trade
in the currency of optimism.
We're tired of doom and
gloom, fatalistic thinking,
the world is going to
hell, and all that.
We need solutions to address the
grand challenges of humanity.
See, I believe in
boundless possibility.
Human beings are
a curious species
because we have the
ability to conceive
of delightful, exotic
future scenarios
and we can actually
move the popular will.
We can pull the present
forward and meet and actualize
any of those possibilities.
That's what we do.
We pull the present
forward into the future.
The future that we
create, that we map out.
Today, we hear a lot in the
media about the energy crisis.
We hear a lot about
sustainability.
strangleholding the planet.
These are all
legitimate concerns,
but again, doom and
gloom has been fatigued.
We need solutions.
So let's talk about
The Solutions Project.
The Solutions Project is
an amazing new initiative
led by Hollywood celebrities,
brilliant civil engineers,
the popular will of some of
the smartest men the world
who have come together
to leverage their brains,
to create a plan to take us
100% renewable here in America.
Literally, 50 plans
for 50 states by 2050
using technology that
already exists today.
The proposal is straightforward.
Eliminate combustion
as a source of energy.
The sun gives us
in one single hour
more energy than we would need
to power the Earth for a year.
And the technology
used to capture
that energy is getting
exponentially faster
all the time.
The fact that less than 2% of
the United States' land mass
would support all of the wind,
solar, and hydroelectric power
generation required to meet
energy demand is amazing.
Now again, it all
comes down to the fact
that we need to make
a cognitive leap.
We need to realize that this
is already possible-- now,
today with existing technology.
We change minds, we
change paradigms.
So again, I encourage
all of you guys
to check out
thesolutionsproject.org, get
educated, get involved,
join the conversation.
Thank you very much.